it's hard for kids to be in a family
where your family is different but it's
especially hard to be in a family where
your hair is not growing black hair is
everything in our community and it's a
huge part of our identity is to be
embraced as part of your kids culture
sometimes translation adoptive families
don't understand how important here it
is it's much bigger than hair it's
really about the care and the confidence
that we're giving to the child through
the hairstyle
[Music]
my name is Tamika Slynt and I am the
executive director of styles for kids
house for kids is a nonprofit
organization that provides haircare
services education and resources for
Translational adoptive families biracial
and kids in foster care I'm gonna wash
your hair now okay
I've always loved doing here and I was
inspired to start this organization
because I met a transracial adoptive mom
she really just needed help now watch my
fingers here she never had experience
working with textured hair before and
the appearance of her girls were not
good I saw the genuine need not only for
her but for so many other moms who were
adopting transfer usually there are not
a lot of families in the
african-american community or the
racists who are adopting so there does
need to be more education about the hair
in the cultural aspects of adopting a
child with different reason
[Music]
we've partnered with several adoption
agencies in Chicago that expressed
interest in having us come there and
teach classes why is hair a big deal who
wants to take a stab at it you're gonna
use your column I want you to practice
this to get your parts more accurate
here we see between 50 and 100 families
per month come into the salon or to our
workshops home does not even it out okay
all over we have helped over a thousand
families with hair care services and
education I have six adopted kids three
year Haitian and three are African
American julia is my middle child she's
eight years old and she has a lot of
hair all right you know when my daughter
was about three years old I realized
that my hair styling skills were not up
to the challenge so I looked online and
found Tamika and she came to our house
and she gave us a whole hairstyling
lesson she showed me how to braid and
took us to the store to pick out
products for my daughter's hair texture
but first the biggest challenge is
learning to part straight had to learn
that oh use gel here that helps who knew
I would want to tell other transracial
adoptive parents that it is your job to
make your kid look decent when you're
out of the house and if you can't do
that naturally on your own and most of
us can't then it's your job to seek out
help from somebody who can teach you
what it does for the self-esteem and
confidence of the kids is just
unbelievable it's amazing to see the
transformation that takes place and it
is a blessing for me to be able to
participate in the lives of the kids
that I serve
the basis at the end of the day when I
go home I feel like I truly made a
difference in someone's life
and that is beyond words
[Music]